i think we are now a story of a of a
demoralized people we have and i mean
that very literally i mean we are
demoralized we have lost
what um
makes humans capable of being
moral beings and and that's things like
it's not just sort of moral um virtues
like goodness and courage and generosity
and not just psychological capacities
like empathy and openness and humility
and things like that but also
intellectual capacities like reason
and memory
and
critical thinking as we've been
discussing and if we are really
demoralized if we've lost
the capacity to be moral beings
um
how do you treat those people what is
the appropriate remedy well punishing
them further
dividing them further
ostracizing them from one another and
what matters to them further is only
going to plummet us further
into this inhuman demoralized kind of
abyss and what what demoralized people
need is is a kind of moral care so we
can rebuild our integrity our system of
wholeness but not just for ourselves but
between one another and so we need to
learn how
you know how is it that our virtues of
tolerance patience
generosity friendship from a civic point
of view were turned on their heads so
that now we normalize and prioritize
things like intolerance i mean the more
intolerant you are the quicker you can
dismiss an outlier from your sphere your
social sphere the better you are
we need to understand how
to revert that to revert back
to that i think older system of virtues
that have proven themselves over the
millennia
to be more
successful not just i think from an
evolutionary strategy as you would
understand or say but
in terms of what's better at
creating human flourishing you know i my
area of specialty is aristotle and
aristotle was a virtue ethicist and he
tried to understand
you know what is it that makes people
happy
and for him it's a kind of flourishing
it's a kind of you know like the
wholeness of a human being needs to
function optimally and that's why
virtue comes from the greek word arete
for excellence so to be virtuous is to
be excellent in all the ways that humans
are capable of being excellent right
it's to develop reason to the best of
our ability it's to develop our
capacities for uh emotional
understanding to the best of our
abilities and so
when we separate ourselves from each
other when we start hating and dividing
each other when we're falling into this
abyss it's not just
that that's
bad for the individual but we're
breaking the integrity of the social
system and now we're seeing the results
of that we see protests in in in canada
and now you have truckers driving across
your country and then i mean we've been
talking for two hours i haven't looked
to see what's going on in the ukraine
but i hate i mean
our world is falling apart and i think
that's because we have a threat we don't
just have this viral threat we have a
threat to the integrity
of our moral systems as individuals and
our moral relatedness to other people
[Music]
you